As you can see on this slide, today we're going to talk about neural networks and back propagation which is actually the process early years I was I was studying this. I was often referring to it as the magical process that um lets the neural networks learn from their own mistakes pretty much like humans but in a more organized fashion and also uh using a little bit more math. So let's let's dive into the topic. I'm I'm sure this is going to be uh exciting and this is a found is is laying a foundation for the
rest of the quarter. Every single algorithm that we'll be discussing in the future without even mentioning is is using a form of back propagation and um so that's why understanding this this lecture and the topics are uh is is very important. Okay. in keeping us with the uh tradition. Let's cover what we've talked about so far. So, I'm sure you now remember uh what we talked about last time. We we said how we can form the objective functions or loss functions what we call here and then um we talked
about regularization. But to do that uh we formulated everything through the XY uh defining the pairs and and scoring function which in this case we are using a linear scoring function as you can see and also uh defining ultimately this this loss function. So this graph that you see on the right is what we uh we drew showing all the process the entire process of learning. There has been some questions um the questions last last le in the last lecture and also even before that that why we only using
the soft max function. I wanted to uh reiterate that it's not the only loss function that we have and we use it's it's um it's one of the most widely used in deep learning and and building especially for the task of classification but there are so many other options that we use for for other task for different tasks even for the task of classification if you've looked at the slides that we've shared on the website I I included this hinge loss loss or um used to be called SVM loss in the reading
assignments on le in lecture two. So in the slides we had uh examples and and everything around the topic of um hinge loss. It is also one of those widely used um loss functions especially in the early years of uh neural networks. And um just to give you a high level understanding of what it is uh this is a loss function that unlike soft max does not turn the scores into probabilities. So turning them into probabilities is not is not the only option. Right? So we can uh use other forms. This this function
encourages the score of uh let me highlight here the score um of the correct items uh which is defined by s yi to be higher than the scores of all other items sj. You can see the the condition here creating a value of zero. if the condition is is true and otherwise what it does is um so as as I said it it encourages the score of the the correct item uh to be higher than the scores of all other items um by at least a margin that number one that you see there is the margin that it creates and then if
the condition is violated the loss increases proportionally um from the margin and this is the visualization. So creating the uh this um visualization of of the function. So this promotes correct scores by penalizing cases where irrelevant items are scored too highly. So again refer to assignment reading assignment in lecture two for examples and uh and to get better understanding of that. Next we have talked about uh general optimization how to find the the best parameters w for for uh the neural network. And in doing
so, we talked a little bit about this lost landscape uh being as a large valley um as as as shown in this um image. And every point on that valley is a different set of weight parameters and we wanted to find the set of parameters W that minimizes that loss landscape. We talked about the fact that the key is is being able to take the gradient of the loss function L with respect to W and use the gradient for optimization in a stepbystep manner which gave us the gradient descent algorithm. Right? So the weights
are basically updated. Although it's very hard for me to see from from this distance what I'm pointing to, but I guess I uh I can guess. So um anyways, in order to walk down the loss landscape towards the minimum value, a step size is defined. and we often uh get take one step with respect to a step step size in the negative direction of the uh gradient. So this was the gradient descent algorithm and in order to optimize we talked about uh two different approaches of numerical gradient and analytical
gradient both of which having pros and cons and we discussed in practice to drive analytical gradients. In practice, we drive analytical gradients and often if it's if it's hard to do the implementation and the math and everything, we check our implementations with neural numerical gradients. And one of the other challenges we talked about was the use of um um incorporating the loss function and its gradient on the entire data set. So if you have a large data set, it's it's very expensive to
um to run the loss function and the the der derivative on the entire data set. And that's why we talked about the idea of mini batches using a number of examples sampled from the data set often 32 um often maybe uh 3264 uh 128 or 256. And that subsampled data is used for identifying the gradients and then taking the steps towards the the minimal. And beyond SGD and a stochastic um gradient descent, we talked about some optimizations of SD SGD with momentum um RMS prom uh prop and and atom optimizer.
And um there were a lot of details that I would refer you to the lecture um the third lecture if you have um any specific uh questions about those. So and then one of the other things that we talked about was the importance of the learning rate and and scheduling the learning rate. And in some of the optimizers we often try to start with a larger value of the learning rate and then start using different types of um decaying the learning rate or or reducing its its value by a factor. Um this is normally uh needed in many
uh optimizers but but in in some of the more recent ones uh atom and it's its variance we often do not need to uh manually or explicitly decrease that because they that that is kind of encoded into the optimizer itself. So with that I uh want us to get uh to the topic of neural networks and and see how we can actually build um neural networks and and solve more exciting and and harder problems. So uh we've so far talked about this this function linear function of w multiplied by x and that is um is is the most basic
neural network that could be defined. It's just one u layer. We will be talking about the layers. And um what I want you to pay attention to here is are these dimensions D and C which are the dimensionality of the input um data input X or or the uh number of features and C is the number of classes basically the number of output uh nodes or or neurons whatever number of outputs we need. And um in order to create a neural network at a second layer, we can define a new set of weights uh referred to as
W2 here. And we apply those to the the previous layer of W1 uh multiplied by X. Again pay attention to the dimensionalities here that we have the C number of outputs and D as the number of uh input features. But then we also define H and and uh that defines uh the number of neurons the number of hidden layer nodes or neurons. That's one point. The second point is this max function that um we'll be coming back to and we'll explain what it it is and what it means. What um the max operation is doing here is to create a
nonlinearity between the linear transformations done by W1 and W2. And this is actually a very very important um part of um the the process. I will talk a little bit about the nonlinearity but also uh look at this this last part before I forget in practice that's right that we are only including w and x we we as we talked about this in the first and second lecture we also uh incorporate a bias just to have a a complete framework so so in practice we also have bias but we don't write it here for the sake of simplicity anyways
the max operation is creating the nonlinearity and it's actually very important because as we talked about um the linear classifiers last in the last few lectures we we said we mentioned that there are so many different problems that we can't uh separate the samples with just one single line right this was one of the examples that um in order to be able to solve this problem with neural networks with linear functions. we need some sort of nonlinear transformation from the original space
to a new space and now in the new space you see that it's they are separable using a a line right so with um in this case it's it's a nonlinear u transformation between the input and then the second space which is mapping the x and y to their polar polar coordinates r and theta but again Um this is just one example. There are so many other um examples too. So um with this example, let's go back to oops uh let's go back to our uh definition of the two layer neural network. As you've probably seen in the
literature and outside uh this class, these types of networks which only depend on weights and u inputs and layers and so on. There are no other operations than multiplication are often referred to as fully connected networks or multilayer perceptrons MLPS. So that's that's one um thing and we can actually stack more and more layers to create better um more um larger networks and in this case again uh pay attention to the dimensionalities and the hidden layers that we have in u in in in the
middle and the dimensionalities that do uh match one after the other. So um back to this visual representation of what the neural network is doing. Um we talked about this when when we had the linear representations that often what happens is the network through the weights is learning some sort of templates. If you remember last uh last week we were talking about these templates that are being learned. So again I'm saying templates they're they're not I mean they are some representatives of the
images but from the data uh depending on what data it was trained on. So these templates in in um what we discussed last week were kind of generated by by these um 10 outputs by applying the W's on top of the input neurons right so um with that now that we have multiple layers more layers now we can actually create some more templates now now we have a layer in the middle that can actually create 100 templates lets um as opposed to just just 10 for a linear classifier although we still have those 10 as well and this
again uh in a very high from a very high level understanding point of view I'm I'm telling you what this means when um we have these 100 neurons in the in the middle we are giving the network the power to create templates for not entire objects but maybe parts of the object for example the classes that you see here We had bird, cat, um, deer, dog, frog, horse, they all have eyes, right? So one of those 10 templates, 100 templates could probably be a part of the objects that is that could be shared
between all of the classes. So from a high level point of view and understanding this um these can form templates and when we come back to the topics of visualization and what we learn from the neural networks this uh this topic will we'll uncover more details about what I I'm talking about right now. So um back to the function max we talked about max uh function the nonlinearity that is created here and in neural network terminology we call that an activation function right it and it's actually
playing a very very important role a pivotal role in in building the model uh building a neural network let's answer this question that we have on the slide what happens if we try to build a neural network without uh one of these activation functions let's say the the max function this will be our function if I remove the the max right so it would be w2 * w1 by x what would happen here yes exactly so as u you can guess and and correctly you mentioned the multiplication of w2 by w1 could
actually be replaced easily with another matrix W3 and then your function becomes just a linear function. So everything could be lumped uh together. So we need some sort of nonlinearity in the middle to be able to give us the uh the power to solve nonlinear uh problems. The function that we just talked uh about is uh ReLU. It's the rectified linear unit. It's a very popular function activation function used in neural networks while there are so many other variants that have have been tested in many uh many other
architectures and and even in the more modern architectures. One of the problems that ReLU has it it sometimes creates dead neurons because it it's it's it's making everything equal to zero if it's uh not positive. Right? So in order to avoid the dead uh neurons leaky relu with this uh type of modeling or uh elu the exponential linear unit are other options. ELU is a little bit better because it has a better zero centered uh function and then there are some newer variations um jello uh gshian error uh linear units
or I don't know I've I've heard both variation jello and yellow so um could be could be used they are often used more often in neuro architecture in in transformers and Um we also have silo or or swish. Uh it's the sigmoid linear unit that um uh that one is is also used in some of the modern CNN architectures. Google was using this for uh efficient some of the variations of their uh models and also in efficient net. Other than these there are um functions like simmoid and uh ten or or tanh that
are often also used for as as activation functions although they do have a few problems because they do squash values in a narrow range and that uh sometimes results in vanishing vanishing gradients. So we often do not use sigmoid or or tang in the middle of the neural networks. They are often used in the later layers where um we want to for example binarize the outputs and and uh things like that. So as I said ReLU is often a good default choice. It's it's very much used in many architectures and there are so many
variations of the same function that we talked uh about. I want to summarize what what we've talked about and then answer some questions. So um we did talk about different uh adding layers and and so on. But I want to highlight that activation functions are often functions that are operating in the layers. And you also have W's which define the weights mapping between the previous layer and the and the next layer. Again, these are fully connected neural networks with very simple uh implementations.
What we only need is to be able to define an activation function. And in this example, if you look at the example, we have um the sigmoid uh function defined as the activation function. And very easily using that activation. The first and the second layers of the hidden values, hidden neurons are uh calculated by applying w1 by x and then also the uh the bias and then applying it um applying the function the the activation function and then same for h2 and the output will be very simply the the dot product for the uh
between the with w3 and the last layer of hidden values creating the output layer. I'll stop here to answer some questions if there are any and then I would love to continue it. That is a great question and the question is how would we choose for a new problem which of these activation functions to use? Um the short answer to your question is uh is yes. It's it's empir empirical in most cases. Um but we often start with with Reu or we go with um standard activation functions being used for
those specific architectures. Uh as I mentioned there are um activation functions that are often commonly used in um CNN's or in transformers and and uh different architectures. So we often uh go with the with the ones that are tested before. But yes, it's it's mostly empirical. If you're if you're designing a new network for a new problem, then uh that's one of your choices that you have to make very much similar to other hyperparameters. So the question here uh is is uh what is
the attribute that is is is basically common between all of these activation functions and uh what it it really does. I will uh give you some examples and I'll I'll go into some of the details of what these activation functions are doing. Uh basically the uh main and and the most important common characteristic here is to create nonlinearity and we're not using a linear function as as the activation. Right? So creating some sort of nonlinearity is is something that is makes makes it very important. And why
do we have so many variations? I told you a little bit about the problems with v vanishing gradients. I told you uh a little bit about uh differentiability of the the functions. They should be uh differentiable because we are using them in neural network. and uh and and uh sometimes having a a proper zero centered value and a smooth function makes it uh much faster to to get converging networks. So there are so many different uh factors these are the the main ones that I uh told you and talked about which play an important
role for defining or designing these uh functions. I'll talk a little bit more about that when I uh go into details of the functions too. In all of the layers we often use um same activation functions but as I said sometimes in the later layers or the output layer we use like a sigmoid activation sigmoid uh function and or tangent function. So um but but commonly yes and uh the question was if we use the same uh across the networks uh the the entire network same function for all of the neurons.
Okay. Um continuing uh to what we were talking about which um is the implementation of these um models these um a neural network. So there is a very simple way um I mean that building a neural network a two layer neuron network in Python is just less than or or 20 lines of code very simple define our network as I talked about the dimensionalities n is the number of samples dn d in is the dimensionality of the input and d out is the dimension of the out the output and h the number of neurons in the
uh hidden layer and we talked about this is just creating X and Y and randomize u randomly init uh initializing W's. Then we have the forward forward pass which means applying W's to the inputs layer by layer and ultimately creating the output the prediction wise predicted wise and then al and and and finally calculating the loss function and outputting that loss value after the forward As we need an optimization pro process, a way to calculate the analytical gradients and use those gradients that are created to
run gradient descent to optimize W1 and W2. Basically taking one step towards the optimal value of the network. But this part calculating the analytical gradient is is the most important um part in in here that we haven't very much uh gone into. So this is the the almost the rest of this lecture is about making this work and scale in um different settings. So um after training and building such a neural network depending on on how many nodes we use in the hidden layer you see that we can we can identify we can get
different patterns uh of separation between the two classes and more neurons often means more capacity to learn more complex functions and better separation. of the uh the nodes the the points if you take a look at this this is this is very much similar to this this pattern I'm showing here is is similar to the one that I showed in the second lecture where we were talking about k nearest neighbor and and when we had only k equal to one the the one nearest neighbor framework it was very much similar to using more
neurons right so same type of arguments happen here that that if we give a lot of capacity to the network then we will have some overfeeding problems uh we won't be able to generalize to unseen data but uh there are many different solutions for this as well and one thing that I as a rule of thumb what I want to highlight here for you is to not use the size of neural network as a regularizer. We don't often use that as a hyperparameter to fine-tune this this network size although we experiment with different um
values of uh the network size and um related hyperparameters. But what we often do is we we go with a a little bit of a um bigger network that we need and then we use the regularization um and then this regularizer and specifically this regular regularization um hyperparameter to to do a different to check the different setups. So what we often tune is the regularization and regularization hyperparameter not necessarily the network size itself. Okay. Um this is the concept of neural networks in a nutshell. But we
have heard about neural networks and how they could be related to uh the biological there are some biological inspirations. Uh so I'll I'll talk a little bit about it but there's a question basically your question is uh why is the model more underfeeding when we increase the value of lambda here? Yes. So um just to quickly answer that question, the value of lambda is controlling how much contribution the regularizer should have in the overall loss, right? And the larger contribution that you have um on
the regularizer and remember that regularizer was defined on W's. So it's constraining the W's. It's giving less freedom to the values on W's, right? So less freedom equals a little bit of like u more generic boundaries not not necessarily giving you those uh like detailed values detailed um uh parts of the the boundaries right so if you constrain the model too much even with regularizer you're also going to get uh values like that decision boundaries like that yes the right regularizer
always overfeeds uh prevents overfeeding. Again you you are creating a compromise a balance between the loss like predicting the actual the right output. So the first part of the loss is predicting the right output. The second part is only playing with the values of the weights doesn't doesn't care about the outputs anymore. If you overweight this you're not going to get very good uh classifiers right. So creating a balance regularizer is always good but nothing is good if you use too much of
it. Right. [Music] >> Um could you go over again why we would want to change the regularization rather than the size? >> So um there are many different reasons. One of them is size of the network. You're building networks. If you're going to build networks that sometimes that you have to run them for few days to to to get some results, right? So networks um we often what we what we often do is we start increasing the quality the number of parameters in networks until we see some levels of
overfeeding. So that's that's the time that we know that the network is is actually understanding the patterns in the data and is trying is is is now able to memorize the data and that's the time that we try to minimize the overfeitting by regularizing the the network. So regularization plays an important factor there. So if we if we go too high on the uh on the number of parameters number of complexity of the network then that's going to be causing a problem. We never never often do that. We often for a new
problem start with smaller u networks and and increase that um after with correct that with the regularizer for a given problem. How do we know how many neurons we need to solve the problem? that's based on uh empirical um research work and and looking at other uh similar type of there is no one prescription for all like you have to look at um other counterparts other other types of networks that were trained in sim on similar data. start from that range and then um often you do a number of
experiments yourself to balance and increase or decrease the complexity of the network. So it's it's often and always pretty much bound to uh exploration. So your question is are there any theoretical and and foundational work uh done to see um which ones to use, which activation functions to use and how many layers to use. There are so many uh research and and and uh papers out analyzing these and and also some methods for optimizing all of these um meta or hyperparameters of of the networks. We're not going to get into uh
them in in detail because again a big part of it is based on very much dependent on the data set the problem you're solving and um so uh the best answer to your question is yes there are some works out there but um but again each of those make assumptions that may not be necessarily true to your uh for your application or problem. So um what what happens is um there are some biological inspirations. Again these inspirations are very much very loose. If there is a neuroscientist sitting here or is watching online um
it's uh do not take all of the examples that I'm um giving you or talking about as u the ground truth. But generally what happens in in neurons and you know this this is a a visualization of a neuron. It does have a cell body that often uh aggregates the impulses carried through dendrites to the cell um body itself cell uh body and then using axons those impulses are carried away to other uh neurons. This is very much similar to what we are doing in our neural networks. We often have a function that captures the
uh the the the the signals all of the previous impulses activations from the previous layers and in the cell body that function is operated on the um on the inputs and outputs the out the the activations and passes them to the next layer. here next neuron. And that's basically why we need some sort of activation function here to to create the impulses to to to increase or decrease the the values. Um, so with that again, uh, that there are many differences between biological neurons and how they could actually be way more
complex than what neural networks we build look like. But um, but generally there are common concepts. Often the neural networks that we build are organized into regular patterns and those patterns are because we want to have better computational efficiency when we be we implement the uh neural networks. Although there has been research creating these complex neural networks and and trying to optimize but um again in terms of results they are almost comparable with the regular functions regular neuron networks that
we often build and we'll be talking about in this class. I can't uh warn you enough on on on on being careful with your brain analogies and um and how this could uh be interpreted. So there are so many differences and um I'll I'll just uh stop here and would be happy to discuss if if anybody was interested in the neuroscience aspect of things as well. So um plugging everything in we did have a scoring function. This scoring function turns the inputs through some W's, some weight vectors or weight matrices into
scores. And um what we often use as the loss function for the network is using those scores either through hinge loss or soft max or other variations. And uh and and in addition to that we defined regularizers which ultimately give us the total loss of a the data loss plus regularizer. And um we talked about this fact that in order to be able to optimize W1 and W2, what we need is to be able to take the derivative of the partial derivative of L with respect to W1 and W2. Uh partial A by W1 and W2. There are so many
different um details that we have to be aware of. First, uh building these functions and then taking the derivatives and and writing them down is often tedious. There are lots of matrix calculations and need a lot of uh work on the paper before you can actually implement a neural network. The other challenge, the other problem is what if you want to change the loss slightly different from what we we've we've done the paper all of the calculations um over. So in that case again we have to um
redo the entire thing and finally um this becomes intractable and sometimes invisible if the loss function is complex. So with complex functions that's going to be even harder. But there is a better idea, something that is often used um in our implementations and I'm going to go into a few examples today just to make sure everybody is on the same page and understands these uh topics. So and and that is computational graphs and the idea of back propagation. computational graphs are are putting together all of the operations
in the neural network and um creating that stepbystep thing and and and start from the inputs and all of the parameters that are uh basically needed and get the loss as the final um output final layer. So in this case we had a loss function which could be a softmax function or a hinge loss function whatever it is it's the loss function which is added to the regularizer the the function rw and r has the has w as the input. So these two added together calculate or or create the loss and before doing the um
or or having the loss calculated we often also need to aggregate X and W and create the score. This is a multiplication function. This is um actually very useful because most of the neural networks that you build are also they have graphical representations and all of these complex functions could be could be shown with the same uh framework and then we can use this and uh and build their computation graph starting from input image or input data. There are a bunch of weights throughout the network. And
finally, there is the loss function. And again, this is useful because um there are some complex neural networks like this um neural touring machine and uh that is actually used for temporal and sequential data. So there's a lot of unrolling of this this machine. And if we have to do all of the work manually by hand, this is going to be un um intractable and and not uh feasible. So and that's why when we build this this computational graph, the solution to that is back propagation. And I want to start with a very simple
example. So we start with a function um f of x y and z which is x + y * z. And if I draw the computational graph for for this function, you see we have an operation which is uh the the the addition operation between x and y and then we have a multiplication between x uh between the that that addition of x1 and y multiplied by z. So given an input setup of x = -2, y = 5 and z = -4. Now actually we can make all of the calculations for and and do this uh the forward pass the uh for stepping forward in the
the neural network. The first step is adding x and y which gives us three. And in order to be able to to understand the steps and step by step, I'm I'm giving the name to it. So Q= X + Y. And if I want to calculate the partial derivatives of Q with respect to both X and Y, it's very simple because we have the formulation here between X and um Q and X and Y. The the formulation is there. the derivatives the partial partial q by x = 1 and partial q by y = 1 as well. So so this is this is a
simple setup we know it exists so just keep it in the back of our minds. Then u the second operation is f= q * z. Again, since we have this function, it's very easy to calculate to to write the partial derivatives, right? Uh partial f by q= z and f by z equals u q. So, it's kind of swap between z and q. I'm hoping that everybody knows all of these from linear algebra. So, and if you don't, you should definitely check it out and remind yourself because these are actually very very important
um algebra in general and uh for the rest of the quarter. what we want and what we need uh in this setup and and to complete this example of back propagation, we need the partial derivative of f with respect to x, y and z. How we start and how back propagation implements this is to start at the front of the network at the end of the network and we start going back back propagating all of the gradients and um this is basically a recursive process that will be u running. So derivative of f with respect to f
is what? It's the thing with respect to itself, right? So it's always the the the the last part the derivative of loss function with respect to itself is is always one. If I want to back prop the first the most immediate one is z. You can see here that um we have z and and for this one if I calculate the derivative of f with respect to z we already have it right f with respect to z is equal to q. So whatever the value of q is goes to this um as as the gradient as well. Next we have um q q is the the next one. next
one that is directly connected to f. So this is also easy to compute because we have um derivative of f with respect to q. We have also already uh calculated that it's equal to z whatever z is that's the value of derivative here minus 4. Next we have y which is directly before q and we know that y and f although we need derivative of f with respect to y but y and f are not directly connected and that's where we use the chain rule where we split the the uh calculation of derivatives with
respect to the variable in in the middle. So partial f by y equals to partial f by q q by y. Right? So this is the this is how the chain rule could be could be written in this case. And now I want to introduce you to two important new terms. Local gradient and upstream gradient. up string gradient is often the gradient that comes from the end of the network to this this um current node that we are in and then uh the local gradient is the gradient of the the the note what the input of the note is with u
gradient of of its output with respect to its input. So it's the local gradient. So defining these is actually not too hard because f by q we already have the value q by y we also already have the value. So it's 1 multiplied by z and the value will become minus 4. Same story when it it's the for the other uh variable x here the local gradient upstream could again be written uh down with this chain rule and it also results in minus 4 and and um gives us because because in both cases the
gradient with respect to x or y was already one. So both of them get the same value. So with this computational setup and the computational graph, it becomes very easy to modularize what we want to do for every single node in the neural network having X and Y as input or whatever else and Z as the output. What we need are first the local gradients which we can always we have the function f it's a function of x and y. So the output gradient of output with respect to the each of the inputs it's easy to
calculate for every single node and what we need to be able to back propagate is the upstream gradient right and the back propagation process is giving us the power to get this upstream gradient step by step. So we when we are at this node we also have the upstream gradient already uh calculated from the future nodes and um that's what we need. What we can do after this is just to multiply the upstream gradient with the local gradient and create what now we call downstream gradients. So the downstream
gradients are going to be upstream gradients for the previous layers. Right? So that's how we calculate that for X. Same story when it comes to Y. So this this whole process gives us the the power to create and and calculate all of these completely locally and step by step go backwards and give it to the previous nodes so they can continue the process. So again this is one of the most um fundamental operations in all of neural networks and many optimization uh processes involving multiple layers
of uh information. If I understand the question correctly, you're saying how can we understand this intuitively what the gradients are doing, right? So let's take one step back and and see why we why we are here to begin with. What we needed was to identify to calculate the gradient of the loss function with respect to w1 and w2 and w's in general to be able to take a step to uh in the negative u direction of in the opposite direction of the gradients to be able to find the the optimal value right optimal loss. So in
order to do that we need gradient of l loss with respect to everything. So what we are doing is we are just moving gradient of L with respect to all variables in the network back to every single value of the network without sitting down and writing the function for the entire network. If the network has um 100 layers, we're not going to be sitting down and writing the function for all of the 100 layers separately. This is how we back propagate step by step to to get the values that we need for that optimization process of every
single weight that is going to be incorporated in the network. Okay. Um example uh another example um so this is a little bit more complex function uh function of weights and x and we have 1 / 1 + e ^ of a linear combination of x and um w. So there are a bunch of multiplications, additions, negation and and the exp function and and ultimately the one over whatever we calculated function. So with with with all of those let's look at this example that we have specific values for w0 x0 w1 x1 and w2 with these given values we
can do the forward pass calculate every single value that we have in uh this process and just to remind you we do have some of the details some of the we we know um For an exp function e ^ of x what its derivative is with respect to x constant uh multiplication always the derivative is the constant value itself 1 /x has a derivative of -1 / x2 uh these are again what we know from algebra. So and and if it's a constant addition it's always the derivative is equal to one. So as I said always in the
very beginning at the at at the end of the network the derivative of L with respect to L is always equal to one. So that's where we start using this uh rule the derivative of function 1 /x. Now we can calculate upstream I said it's it's one always at the end. The local gradient could be one min -1 / x 2. What is the value of x that whatever the input is? So this calculation results in minus uh.53. So.53 is the downstream gradient which defines the upstream gradient for the next one. And in the next again the
function here is just a constant addition where we know that the local gradient equals to one. So one multiplied by upstream gradient same value goes back uh next step is the exp function. So for that again the lo the upstream we already have the value for the local gradient it's e to the power of x what is x the input of to the of this uh step minus one. So calculating this will give us minus.2 and this goes back to the next step. Here we again have a multiplication with a constant number which defines the
local gradient equal to that um number that that uh constant value and defining the new gradient downstream gradient and going back now here we have an addition function where we are getting some um data some some information sorry two inputs um of the different values here. And again, if you want to calculate the upstream gradient, it's 02 already. We have it. The downstream at the local gradients will be equal to uh one because it's just an addition between two values and an addition. The
derivative of x + y with respect to both x and y is always one. So both inputs will be the same. Then we have multiplication operations with multiplication. Uh upstream gradient again we have the values and the local gradients with respect to a multiplication val is if we always have say for example a multiplied by x. The derivative of this with respect to x is always a the other variable. Right? So here for the first one it's minus one which is the value of x and for the second one it's two which
is the value of w. So the other other variable whatever the value it has. So with that we can calculate everything and then then also calculate the the ones with respect to w1 and x1. Again, we made all of these calculations so we can identify how much W should be changed in order to step towards the optimal point in the neural in the network. So this was another example. There are so many different ways to draw a computational graph. This was not the only one that I I explained. So we can actually lump all of the function
together and define a sigmoid sigmoid because this is basically sigmoid of a linear function. Right? So the linear function could be here and then all of these operations could be defined as sigmoid. And actually sigmoid is interesting and very useful to um to use because the local gradient using sigmoid is dependent on sigmoid itself. So the local gradient of sigmoid with respect to the variable x if we do the calculations and simplify it's 1 minus sigmoid multiplied by the sigmoid of the same x. So it's actually a very very uh
useful uh framework. So anyways uh useful function and easy and in order to calculate the upstream um the the the downstream gradient again what the upstream gradient was was value one and if I calculate the local gradient which is this function replacing x with what the input was which is one it's it's how this will be calculated multiplied by one will be 2 which is actually the exact same value that we had from before doing it um separately. I want to summarize and and say that um there are few patterns in in the data
often um very much in for the for the for the nodes that um we can actually kind of memorize. uh there is AD gate for the AD gate it's always a gradient distributor because of the the the properties of addition that I explained the gradients will uh remain the same as whatever its input is for the multiplication gate it's the it's a swap function again I told you gradient of xy with respect to x is y with respect to Y is X. So it's kind of a swap and then um there is copy gate in the copy gate.
copy gate it the operation that happens is is just an addition of what is coming uh to the network and to the node or gate the gate and then ultimately there's a max gate which is actually something that we use quite often very much similar to the relu function max um gate has the gradient of because it's it's up it's taking a max between its inputs so whichever the max value was you just relay the or route the gradient towards that um direction. So with that um it's it's very simple to
now implement a neural network forward pass compute all of the steps and then in the backward pass we start computing the gradients and step by step I explain that the gradient of the uh fun the loss function with respect to itself is always one and then we start from the end of the network and go up. You can see here that we are going uh up. So this is the sigmoid function calculating the gradients. Then going up that was the add gate. We had another add gate and then we had two multiply gates which basically very simply um
gives us the implementations. And with this type of formulation, what we can do is just do some implement modular modularize every um function in the in neural network and create the forward and backward APIs for every single function that we need in the neural network. So in this case this is a multiplication gate that because for multiplication we need to access the inputs for use in the backward pass we often save them memorize them but then calculate the forward pass values and then the backward pass calculate the
gradients. So this means we can write our functions and put the forward and backward passes all in. And this is how PyTorch operators right now look like. If you look at the sigmoid layer for example, it's just the forward pass. Although um in this very function, it's not implemented. It's it's somewhere else in the C++ code in the C code um that it's actually implemented in PyTorch. But then the backward pass of sigmoid is also calculating the same function that we just uh talked about.
So with this um the so far what we've what we've said uh and I actually covered most of the examples that I wanted to cover in um using the scholar values. All of the examples were were were just scholar values. But we know that um all of these operations could actually be implemented in vector or matrix uh forms. Just expanding on that um piece here. Um we talked about this that with the scholar to scholar setting so far what we've talked about uh for any input x and y being scholars. So um the derivative
will also be a scholar which means if we change x by a small amount how much the value of y uh will change if it's now vectorzed and and there are vectors if if x is a vector of n elements and y is a scalar a vector to a scalar uh derivative then in this case the derivative will also be a vector. vector and every single element in that vector means if we change x by a small value that that value then how much the amount of y changes then the entire amount of y because it's just one single value and
then there are also vector to vector uh frameworks where x and y both of them are vectors of arbitrary size n and m in those cases the derivatives will form a matrix or what we call Jacobians and and there uh for each of the elements in X if it changes by a small amount then uh this derivative tells us how much each element of Y will be changed again look at the sub u scripts here they are not um completely they're not the They could be different for every single element in this jubian. There has a there's a clear
meaning. And then how we can do or or um see it and visualize it in here is that if you want to backrop uh with vectors say xy and z are vectors of size dx, dy and dz. Again the loss derivative um L is the loss itself is always scholar because that's always one value we want to uh minimize but then calculating the upstream gradient will result in also a vector DZ same size as its u um variable Z and same story happens when it comes to downstream gradient in in downstream gradients. U actually
before going to downstream gradients let me tell you a little bit about the local gradients where we have uh gradient of Z with respect to X and uh Y and in this case that's the part that I said there will be Jacobians because now the matrix the the gradients will turn into matrices. So we have two Jacobian matrices here um defined by the size of their input by multiplied by the size of the output and um and then this results in downstream gradients that are multiplication of upstream and the um
local gradient and there we get same size as the inputs. X itself. So the we will have a vector again here because the input was a vector same size in terms of the gradients. Um I just mentioned that gradients of variables with respect to loss always have the same dimensionality as the original variable itself as also shown in this um slide. So um back prop with vectors was that's just one uh one example here. Let's say we have a function which is the max of zero and x. That's that's the relu function.
So this is an elementwise function that takes the input takes a max between zero and if it's non zero if it's uh non- negative it passes through otherwise replaces it with a zero. Assume you get some upstream gradients and there now we need to build a Jacobian matrix here and this Jacobian matrix in this case because this is an elementwise operation it doesn't have any dependence on any of the other inputs only the dependence is on the value itself. This is a very sparse matrix only has value on the main
diagonal. And those values are actually either zero or one depending on if the max was actually um taken or a zero was if the the value was passed through or or just the zero was replaced um with it um in in its place. multiplying it by the upstream gradient gives us the downstream gradient and um this is how um the calculations are done. As I said, Jacobian here is mat is is a sparse because in this case the operation is element wise and that could actually be instead of in the in the backward pass
instead of calculating that huge sparse jacobian matrix what we do is just use these rule-based calculation of the gradient for for this max function. So we don't really store that that matrix and and do not calculate that because we know the how the the function uh operates. And then this could also be extended to matrices um and even tensors if the inputs are not vectors. They are high higher dimensionalities uh high dimensionality data. So in those cases again the gradients with respect to the
variables would be of the same size as that specific variable and calculating the upstream and downstream calcul uh matrices and derivatives is going to be done same as how we discussed uh and and showed earlier for vectors and then when it comes to the local gradients although um however it's going to be a huge matrix a huge jacobian because we have a matrix as in as the output and the matrix as the input and then the local gradients will be the same size as the multiplication of its input size and and the output size. So
it's it's going to be a huge matrix by itself. Let me give you an example. If this is input X and W as as input for a node for a gate with matrix multiplication, what happens is uh and and generates this this Y as the output. Calculating derivative of L with respect to Y gives us these Jacobian matrices. And say we have a batch size mini batch size of 64 and dimensionality of those matrices is is 4,96 then this means that that Jacobian matrix that huge Jacobian matrix will be over 256 GB for just one single multiply
um matrix multiplication. So in order to simplify this we often um what we do is we try to look at the values and how they impact each other. For example, what part of parts of Y will be affected if element one element of X um gets impacted. So there uh x uh n and d this this specific one often affects just one row in the output. And this is um this basically helps us uh identify for calculating each of these nodes. We don't need to create the huge jacobian. we can actually write the backward pass
functions uh specifically for matrix multiplication uh in a more efficient way and uh I'm almost done so you answer this question how much does x and d affect the value of y and m so this is y and m that is um getting impact from x and d how much Does it get impact? It means that what should I place or or put as its gradient with respect to um the the specific value x and d. Just to remind you this is a multiplication operation. In multiply gates it should be a swap right. So whatever this this uh the answer to this question
is something a value in W right remember that we had this multiplication gate which was a swap multiplier so there is a swap happening here so the value of X being affected uh affecting Y one of the elements in Y is going to be dependent on a W that is in row D defined by the X matrix and column M defined by the Y matrix. So it's swapping the values. It's the same swap but here now we have to look at the the giant matrices and find which which uh specific element uh it should be and then based on that we
can actually replace the entire thing with matrix multiplication matrix operations. The gradient of L with respect to X will be defined as this simple matrix operation. And then the gradient of L with respect to W will be defined as this very simple multiplication. Again swap here for X we include the entire W. For W we include the entire X and do the uh multiplications. These formulas makes it easy to to implement larger and and harder operations and um get them implemented in the backboard passes. All right, we're done.
Um just to summarize, we talked today about fully connected neural networks. We went through all the steps needed for back propagation, the forward passes, backward passes and next session we will be getting into the topic of convolutional neural networks. Thank you.